Speaker 1: One of the things we've learned, if
we've learned anything over the last few years is
that when they say they're going to do something,
we should assume that they're telling the truth.
And a great example of this
is in the lead up to the 2020
election. All of the talk about the ballots
can't be trusted. The absentee ballots can't
be trusted. Vote by mail. It's all a scam. It's
all corrupt. It's all lending itself to fraud.
They were telling us what they were going to say
after the election and at 2:00 a.m. 2:15 a.m.
Eastern Time. Whatever it was on the night of the
2020 election, Trump came out and said he won and
then immediately started casting doubt into the
absentee ballots. And we know what the story is.
They're still telling that lie, and roughly half
of Republicans have been convinced of that. And
so when a couple of months ago, Donald Trump told
us, we are going to be supporting the right people
to run the elections in 2022 and 2024, and I told
you they're telling us what they're going to do.
They're putting people in place so that instead
of, you know, Brad Raffensperger in Florida,
I'm sorry in Georgia who said, I'm not going to
find you the 11000 votes you need because you
didn't win not going along with it instead of a
Brad Raffensperger, they'll have someone who's
compliant and someone who's going to go with it.
And that is exactly what is starting up right now.
The Guardian reports alarm as Trump backs Big Lie
candidates for key election posts in Michigan.
It's almost a non-story in the sense that they
said they were going to do it. It was obvious
they were going to do it, and now they're doing
it. A Trump is takeover of the battleground state
is raising eyebrows over concerns of the
end of free and fair elections. Remember,
this was Trump just about a month ago.
Speaker 3: There'd be a lot sharper the next
time when it comes to counting the vote. There's
a famous statement. Sometimes the vote counter
is more important than the candidate,
and we can't let that ever, ever happen
again. They have to get tougher and smarter.
Speaker 1: So he told us that they were going to
do it and they are doing it. Trump and his allies
are backing numerous candidates in the coming
midterm elections across the U.S., including
in other vital states like Arizona and Georgia.
But his intervention in Michigan raises particular
eyebrows due to its role in helping Trump to win
2016 before flipping back to Democrats in 2020.
The former U.S. president and his close ally, Mike
Lindell, the Mike Pillow I'm sorry, the MyPillow
CEO are giving strong backing to a Michigan lawyer
and key promoter of debunked election fraud
charges, who is seeking the Republican nod to
be the state's next attorney general. Trump plans
to hold a fundraiser for Matthew DePinho on Ma